hey what's going on it's bill burr um
and it's time for the monday morning
podcast for monday
for monday august no october oh this
thing's a [ __ ] show already october 4th
2021 what's going on how are you
how's it going
now my voice is a little hey i'll tell
you it's a little rough there okay
uh did a bunch of shows this week
um i went out to meet me and saint luis
me me at the fair and i worked at the
fabulous the fabulous fox theater
um i performed there before
and uh there's an incredible stevie ray
vaughan uh
tattoo uh
autograph
right on the door on the inside of the
door in the green room and every time i
see that i just cannot believe it
um so i got to do two nights there
working with dean delray
getting prepared
to shoot my show at red rocks which
hopefully potentially will you know
would be a special
so
you know i crushed the first
red rock show a few weeks ago
and i was like all right my act is up
and running that felt good man that felt
really good like i wouldn't
you know because i was just filming this
thing just because i wanted to have
proof that i i was there
because you know you never know if you
you never know if you get to go back
right so
uh but it felt good enough to be a
special
so i was like all right we'll shoot the
next one and we'll see what we got my
hack feels good and i'm like all right
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
you know do a couple spots in la and
then i'm going to run my hour one night
somewhere i'll go on last and just run
it just so i got it and i'm up and up
and running and then lo and behold this
[ __ ] cold that's going around around
that lingers for like two weeks
my kid brought it home from school
and i got it and i had it beat by sunday
last week um
you know when i went to the rams game
against the uh tampa bay uh tom brady's
and um
i smoked two cigars like an [ __ ]
brought my immune system down to nothing
and uh the cold came right back
and i was like [ __ ] so now you know and
then the whole [ __ ] week i was like
trying to get over the goddamn cold and
all that [ __ ] i didn't do any spots
i think i went out one night
bombed after don l rawlings at the laugh
factory and i'm like you know this is
just this is just what the this always
[ __ ] happens like this right sounds
like all right maybe i'll feel better
monday i'll go out there and i just
didn't you know just didn't end up going
out
no didn't i didn't i'd run it one more
time i forget what so i was looking at
my act or whatever
so i get to st louis and just
fortunately the first night there was
just such a [ __ ] great crowd
that i was able to go out there
get in the groove of it you know
everything [ __ ] up a couple of jokes
but nothing noticeable and then the next
night
it was it was humming right
but then the next day i got to go to red
rocks and i swear to god anytime i'm
shooting something
shooting a special whatever i always get
this feeling of dread and i start
thinking why do i do this which was the
name of my first special you know i'm
inherently a shy person i should have
just whittled wood and just sat in the
corner and stayed away from me i was
like no bill this is the [ __ ]
eight-year-old you
you always do this you revert back to
that orange-headed kid with no friends
or whatever the [ __ ]
it was and you just gotta push through
this [ __ ] so i was like all right this
is normally where i go i think about
retiring
like i don't want to do this anymore why
don't i just downsize my life and just
[ __ ] not deal with people
[Music]
like i can testify so
anyway we go uh
we fly out we go to denver
and uh
land and everything and i don't know
something i get to redrock second i get
there i do a sound check i'm goofing
around with mike binder the director who
also shot paper tiger and i just got
myself in a stupid mood and i just
was like all right
i hope this goes well but the first one
went so well like i was getting in my
head like i didn't want to disappoint
you know mike or anybody else by not
doing well and uh
last time i was with bartnik this time i
was with dean delray
and uh
dean went up [ __ ] murdered
murdered
um
and they had a little break there you
know and i was just sitting there just
[ __ ] just
second i get on stage i'm fine it's just
the waiting i believe tom petty said
that the waiting is the hardest part and
for me it definitely is then once i got
out there
um
i don't know it just all [ __ ] came
together and i got off stage i was like
that felt really good
and everyone's saying i think that was
better than the last one i think that's
the one and blah blah blah so i will see
how this thing looks
um
and if it looks good
i'm kind of ahead of the game because i
haven't even done my tour yet with this
hour so then my plan would be i'd you
know
put it out next year while i do my tour
and write the new hour
bing bang boom i hit the ground running
could be [ __ ] great
could be great so i want to thank
everybody that came out
in st louis and uh and out red rocks and
then afterwards you know i did two
nights in a casino just outside of
minneapolis
minnesota swung by mats got myself a
juicy lucy as a reward for [ __ ]
crushing it
at uh at red rocks
and um
i went out and had two really really fun
shows
in minneapolis because all the stress
was gone and like it was really just
extra silly and stupid it was just a
[ __ ] great
great trip and i'll tell you the old me
the old me billy no kids billy no life
billy nothing to come home to right the
old me would have hung around for that
uh vikings browns game to check out that
new stadium that if all the viking fans
gave me [ __ ] when i was [ __ ] you know
fanning myself about sofi stadium
um
but you know i got kids so i ended up
you know
coming back wasn't that bad you know
coming back from minneapolis you can get
out to la you know you get not too bad
of a headwind you can get out here a
little over three hours which i thought
was [ __ ] awesome
some reason i thought it was four hours
to chicago so i thought minneapolis we
were more north i don't know we must had
a tailwind
we left it like 9 15 then we left landed
12 no
yeah something like that three and a
half hours i forget what the hell it is
so anyway um
i think i have that
in the rear view mirror i think i have
the special i'm just hoping that it
looks good if it doesn't then i can take
at another's place
and i had a great practice and then i
also have this thing in my back pocket
is something that i shot because we
spent the money
um enough to make it look like a special
so i was very excited about that
um so i can put that to bed and now i'm
old billy check ride now now i'm just
flying a helicopter
every day all day getting ready for my
check ride for this instrument rating
coming up i don't know when if i'll take
it this month or the end the beginning
of next month i don't know what but i'm
just [ __ ] go i'm going to get that
behind me
okay i get the special behind me i get
the rating behind me
and then you know f is for family is
about all wrapped up and that series is
done i have all of that stuff off of the
table
and all i have is my stand-up and
spending time with my wife and kids
which is
be [ __ ] amazing
you know and flying helicopters you know
[ __ ] am i going to [ __ ] about so um
yeah that is the deal
so anyway it's uh sunday night and as
i'm taping this in the background i have
the new england patriots verse
the tom brady tampa bay buccaneers
it's 7-6 14 40 to go in the third
quarter
and um
i got a bad feeling here in the second
half
i mean i gambled this week i just i
don't i just go up against versi on the
version on the uh anything better
podcast
for bet mgm
so we pick four games a week and right
now i'm three you know who'd you pick
bill i picked the bills lay in 17
and they [ __ ]
they got [ __ ] dropping the ball
we might win this game um i don't think
so
i we needed that drop i can tell you
that because i know tom [ __ ] laid
into him in the halftime
getting these guys
getting these guys going so anyway
plowing ahead here i um
i had the bills laying 17.
josh allen his first throw of the game
throws a pick i was just like ah [ __ ]
i'm gonna lose this bet but they just
destroyed him 40 to nothing
then i had the arizona cardinals
versus the la rams
and uh i was getting a [ __ ] there you go
troy brown not trey brown antonio brown
wrong brown
um
that was a flag down there was a flag
down
holding
legal use of the [ __ ] hands on those
other [ __ ] guys go [ __ ] yourself
repeat the down third down
three fingers
um
you know what's funny when brad was i
think the patriots fans did it perfectly
they cheered tom when he came out on the
field
and the highlight
and all that [ __ ] when the game started
when he ran out with the buccaneers he
got booed and that's perfect i know
there's gonna be a bunch of [ __ ]
sports talk radios like could you
believe they booted after everything
let me show some class it's just like no
dude
we we gave you the tip of the cap and
now it's game time we want to [ __ ]
win
jesus christ
yeah that was a hold and a half
look he was holding a [ __ ]
thing a jiffy pop i couldn't even tell
that that was a helmet i [ __ ] hate
our silver helmets ever said that before
this is my favorite uniform they they've
had since they went to the flying elvis
as far as from the neck down like that
blue with a little bit of red stripe it
looks [ __ ] great but i don't
understand what the [ __ ] was wrong with
pat patriot those ones in the mid 70s
where was the all red jersey with the
white number
and [ __ ] paul revere
with the football i mean that was for me
then the black cleats
that was the [ __ ] right there um
anyway
um
and then i had uh the seattle seahawks
getting three i think i might have been
getting five with
arizona i don't know
not only did all my teams cover they all
[ __ ] won so we'll see here it's my
chance to go if i go four and oh here
then i'll be eight and eight on the year
because i went two and two one and three
and one and three i was getting my ass
kicked it's hard to pick games when you
got kids you know when you got nothing
to [ __ ] live for you can watch this
[ __ ] and look at stats
i'm not saying it helps but you do a
little better than [ __ ]
whatever the hell i just was three and
five i was three no
what was i you know i had eight losses
i was four and eight that's what i was
[ __ ] pathetic
so um
anyway i am back here i'm gonna be
studying my ass off i got my flash cards
right here
and um
and i'm just gonna be flying flying
flying and then coming home and doing
the simulator
i get one of those little [ __ ]
computer games
and just doing all the uh
approaches holds and all of that [ __ ]
and just i'm gonna i'm gonna get this
thing man i gotta uh
it's been a long time coming so i'm
gonna get this thing i'm gonna get it in
the past i'll be a better safer pilot
and all of that [ __ ] and then i'll never
fly in that stuff
[Laughter]
as far as my piloting goes i'm old billy
nice day oh billy sun's out okay sun's
out bill's out that's how i [ __ ] fly
i look at the visibility if it doesn't
say one zero i don't go second i am out
nine eight you know whatever i'll do a
quick little one
i start scene seven i'm like yeah
[ __ ] i don't i don't need to where am
i going
where am i going that's the advantage
you have of not flying for a living
you fly for a living you have to kind of
go pretty much no matter what unless
it's the worst [ __ ] day ever
um
so
anyway
when i woke up this morning
i saw this uh
i saw this um
that urban meyer was was trending
and i guess he went back to the house
state game had a couple of pops
and uh you know so everyone was giving
him [ __ ] about his behavior but i just
love like how come they don't give the
woman [ __ ] too you know
it's like what the [ __ ] is she doing i
don't get her in trouble or anything but
just [ __ ] crack me up but i always
just look at that [ __ ] like whenever i
see things like that i go that's between
him and his wife what does that have to
why do i need to know that that [ __ ]
happened and then who's the rat who sat
there and filmed them like they give a
[ __ ] about the sanctity of marriage they
don't give a [ __ ] they're just trying to
get likes and trying to get hits and
trying to make [ __ ] money but having
said that jesus christ your urban
maya my god
i i will say this if they jacksonville
was two and two
he doesn't have that many drinks
one in three maybe you know you go up
there oh and four you know some [ __ ] can
go down
get a little hammered you know the
[ __ ] achy breaky heart comes on you
know
and those chicks they live in ohio what
are they gonna do they don't have a
dream they got nothing going on
right
i actually didn't watch the video i just
saw it it looked like he was going to
pass out
he looked like like that guy in the
titty bar
you know that the stripper sort of wakes
up and leads him back over the atm again
he was like that level drunk
um
these goddamn cell phones i swear to god
i swear to god man it's just the [ __ ]
you know the guy had a bad night now
look at him now what's gonna happen
[Music]
[Laughter]
um
anyway good pats driving down the field
i don't think i've ever bet against the
patriots in my life
this was my way of handling this game
emotionally
that if tom came in and kicked our ass
at least i'd win money
and if we win it's the pats and i'll
feel good
so um this whole game i have not even my
even though i got money on it i can't
bring myself to [ __ ] root against us
there you go there you go
all right let's see second and one
second and one what's going on here it
looks like they're gonna run they got
two guys in the backfield are they gonna
run into the strong side that's what it
looks like
right up the gut nothing everybody knew
it even the comedian all right um
so anyway my next run of dates
is uh
i'm doing a bunch of shows
in atlanta and what's cool is i have uh
some stand-up friends that live there
now so i'll have a
my um my usual i'll have an opener and
then i'll have
a couple of my friends popping in
to do uh
to do some guest spots or whatever
um when i'm honestly one of my favorite
cities to go to
even though the traffic is absolutely
well speaking of teddy bars
speaking of the old titty bars there
um
i'll be back in uh
atlanta why do i try to do a podcast
when there's a game on in the background
why do i do this oh [ __ ] no that's an
incomplete pass [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
what is with these defensive guys
wearing like
field goal kicker numbers
five nine
six
was it the [ __ ] 1930s
be oh jesus that's a fumble all day but
i don't understand he made a football
move right
i don't know what he did
he looked like a guy trying to carry too
much [ __ ] out of a room
you know you know when you grab the
laundry you don't fold it you just got
to grab a bunch of socks and underwear
and stuff i'll bring it upstairs and do
it and you [ __ ] drop it
every goddamn time
um
anyway so i wish i had some more stories
from the road i didn't do [ __ ] i just
literally stayed
in the hotel the entire time
you know quarantining
um
minnesota was a trip
you know that was probably the most
hardcore we're not getting vaccinated
crowd that i went in front of so i had a
[ __ ] blast with them
um
you know it never ends it never ends you
know i had a blast when i would go into
[ __ ]
trump cities i had a great time when i
would go into hillary cities and just
trash hillary
watching these people getting so [ __ ]
mad
[Laughter]
this is why i was so in the sticks
not even just that far in the sticks but
i was just in minnesota
right
and i did a bit on that gmc sierra or
the gmc pickup truck with the [ __ ]
the tailgate that you can fold 58
different [ __ ] ways
it's about as obscure
as it gets
right it killed you would think that i
was doing a joke about the president
absolutely killed i was talking about
people being too fat to [ __ ] even
just roll into their trucks anymore you
can't even just put your leg up on the
bumper you need the tailgate to turn
into a staircase and i was joking that
they should just have like you know you
know those old people chairs that
[ __ ] take you up the staircase
those electric ones they're gonna have
that next
people just keep [ __ ] chowing
um
so anyway
um it was great to get back home though
seeing my kids my son is a friggin riot
strong as hell his big thing now is we
got like this big uh like a playpen type
thing but we keep all his toys in it we
dump everything out and spread it all
across the room and then he just starts
laughing and he picks the stuff up
and he runs over to to the crib and he
does like the old tomahawk
dunk from way back you know when you put
it all the way behind your head
the double hand it's funny because
sometimes he does it and if it's like a
ball
it'll hit his it'll hit his
the top of his head and it rolls down
the back goes the wrong way like a um
like a fumble or something like that so
i filmed him doing it and afterwards
i put my hand out for him to give me a
high five no the low five the old school
low five and he brought his hand all the
way back and [ __ ] slammed his hand
down
i was psyched both my kids slap five
like that
they don't do that little you know
dead fish thing
some of these people do what am i
talking about here people i i you know
i'm gonna have to put pause on this game
because my [ __ ] train of thought
is gonna be nowhere here with this
[ __ ] watching this goddamn game look
at this christ they're on the 40-yard
line we don't need this [ __ ] leonard
fournette right up the middle
nothing
he looks old as [ __ ] by the way i don't
know when he they had him [ __ ]
running around to the outside
he looked like me playing touch football
i don't know why he just looked slow is
that crazy
for a 53 year old white comedian
be saying a black running back in the
nfl looks slow
to say he looks like me
um
anyway oh you know what's funny about
red rocks right
absolutely breathtaking scenery right
but because we were filming
we had a spotlight on me
and it was so in my eyes i could not yes
right there fred the old [ __ ] slap
down and round
deflected past sorry the spotlight was
so in my face
i couldn't see any of the red rocks
so i felt like i was talking into this
giant walk-in closet but the energy of
the people was amazing and like four
times
during the show
you know when the wind was blowing
towards the stage this cloud of weed
smoke
would wash over me and i was just like
this is [ __ ] amazing
am i going to lose this [ __ ] bet
look at this [ __ ]
this is going to be everybody you know
the next day is it time to panic
down to tampa bay i'll tell you you know
they started off all right
it's it's a weird thing you know you got
all the same players they're all back
but i got to tell you these la you know
if i'm if i'm looking at tampa bay
and i'm looking at the last two weeks
i got to tell you i i don't like what i
see and if i'm bruce ahrens i gotta be
thinking when is tom brady gonna take
over the head coaching reigns like he
did last year so we can win another one
i watched at lsu auburn game
right up into the end and i had to go on
stage so i missed the ending i don't
know how we ended up losing i knew they
had the [ __ ] ball
um
what else did i watch i watched like
another upset
um
i don't know i'm just hoping ohio state
loses again
not because i really give a [ __ ] i just
love when they lose
and just listening to their fans
talking about why they should still be
in the playoff it's like a [ __ ]
tradition now
like ohio state could literally have two
losses in the big ten and they'd be like
okay i know all right they were early in
the season okay now just listen to my
argument i'm gonna tell you why we
should still be in the playoff then they
go in the playoff and they get [ __ ]
smoked like nine times out of ten they
lose by [ __ ] 40 points so i'm sitting
there going why do they keep putting
these [ __ ] [ __ ]
in the playoffs to have a boring game
and get [ __ ] smoked and i just think
that it's got to be a ratings thing
you know it's kind of like how they put
notre dame notre dame was on
before you could buy like packages and
[ __ ]
um college football packages or whatever
[ __ ] notre dame was on every single
week and they sucked for like 15 20
years and they were just on because
everyone would watch them
so i think ohio state has a little bit
of that going on
um
you know i don't know how strong the big
ten is but i don't know they played one
game outside and they got their [ __ ]
asses kicked and that's what ends up
happening then they talk all this [ __ ]
about how tough the big ten is and then
they go in like i said nine times out of
ten they end up [ __ ] it seems like
they lose by like 20.
um
this has been a tough podcast for the
[ __ ] urban meyer fans hey did they
take down the statue of urban meyer now
now that he was there getting a [ __ ]
sort of a buffalo wild wings lap dance
like how does the math work on that um
i don't know
we shall see man i've been one of those
places in a while
oh speaking of that dude i gotta like
you know
once i get this uh
the uh instrument rating then my next
thing's gonna be is to get rid of this
[ __ ] covet wait man i gotta
i gotta knock this [ __ ] off
i did pretty good when i was out there
then i got to minnesota it was like the
day after
the big [ __ ] stress thing so i got a
burger like an [ __ ]
i didn't eat my salad that night you
know because i had the burger of me
going hey man
let's eat something else that's fun
then i had like a mini pizza and a
[ __ ] chocolate chip cookie and i woke
up this morning and my my belly looked
like how it does usually at the end of
the day like what the [ __ ] did i do i
woke up like that i was like all right
ain't going out that way we're going out
so i got um
i tried i tried when i was in st louis i
really tried i went to there was a
[ __ ] smoothie place
right near the hotel
and i walked over there and they had
this peanut butter protein
[ __ ] smoothie and i go is this thing
healthy and she goes yeah it's delicious
so i said all right so she makes it for
me
and i had gone to the gym i did legs and
eggs
and um
oh look at that synchronized celebrating
of the sack there
i don't know what that was
they should have been doing that in a
pool they look like synchronized
swimmers here they just sacked mac jones
it was weird i don't know did they both
do it
oh maybe the other guy was just
supporting him
it's actually kind of interesting they
framed it nice little music video for
half a second
um
the only thing i worry about mack jones
is he always seems to have his legs like
awkwardly underneath him as some 300
[ __ ] pound guy
is bringing him down to the ground
that's like the second or third time
this game alone oh jesus christ
the field goal kicker again number nine
and like all young people he is
impressed with himself
[Laughter]
what happened
he just went on oh
the big boy cleared him both out
that guy's a problem not number nine
that other guy
that was like a [ __ ] car with the
break off just started rolling you know
and then the owner tries to get in front
of it he just did that to a [ __ ]
offensive lineman
patriots punting out of their own end
zone dude could they have more [ __ ]
graphics on the field they're making
like the grass different colors it's
like i get it this is the 10 yards
[ __ ] patch ball baby
[Applause]
come on you old bastard say it's ours
ah jesus
52 that's wishful thinking come on
no no
how the [ __ ] did they get it there was
like three of us down there
neither one's letting go
what's the other guy doing
the other guy there was side control
there's like two guys like to [ __ ]
hold in the hope diamond and there's
another guy
you know what that's like that's like
when a famous person dies and that's
like the distant relative that shows up
like i [ __ ] him for a week can i have
a car
uh
this right here is why you tape a game
this is gonna take for [ __ ] ever
they're gonna have to go under the hood
they gotta talk this guy's got his hat
off yeah
what get the [ __ ] out of here
unsportsmanlike conduct your ass
i don't like this karl maldon looking
[ __ ] what is the problem
what the [ __ ] just happened
why is he wearing number 18.
oh he got pushed out of bounds
oh and then he didn't try to get back in
but well [ __ ] yeah i didn't notice that
i was watching that like three times
that's that's the right call i'm sorry
carl mauldin
the [ __ ] guy was running down the
whole goddamn nah
yeah i know but then you should have got
back in bounds slater
do they have to let him get back in
bill looks like he's standing on the
front of a yacht right now i mean a
sailboat
oh jesus that would have been [ __ ]
huge we needed that
oh god
all right
the [ __ ] guy talked to him looks like
drew bledsoe from behind doesn't he
i'm just assuming you guys are watching
this on youtube at this point somebody's
uploaded the game everybody else is like
bill we don't give a [ __ ]
what are you talking about
all right how long into this podcast am
i because i get oh i think it's time to
put my daughter to bed i'm gonna have to
i swear to god i'm gonna be more [ __ ]
focused
all right i gotta hit stop right now i
gotta put my daughter to bed and then
i'm coming back
all right
um
comment
back
all right i'm back well i don't know
what the [ __ ] happened but i take it
brady went right down the field and
scored a touchdown
three minutes left in the third quarter
so i guess it's uh you know
nice
[ __ ] 10 12
play drive is that what it was ate up
the whole [ __ ] third quarter
all right we have a nice little dump off
there all right let's let's let's let's
let's let's get back to the goddamn
podcast here
i swear to god if i lose this bet
the patriots better win
there you go first ah
patriots
kind of an [ __ ] bets against his own
[ __ ] team
i don't know
someone like me
does that fit your thing all right let's
let's do a little some reeds here all
right helix everybody alex
helix sleep has a quiz that takes just
two minutes to complete and matches your
body type and sleep preference to the
perfect mattress for you why would you
buy a mattress made for someone else
with helix helix you're getting a
mattress that you know will be perfect
for the way you sleep
everybody's unique
and helix knows that
man they're really catering to the uh
the me generation of social media
everybody's unique and special and
you know has a right to a medical
opinion
and to question doctors and
and get that second opinion from someone
who isn't a doctor so they have several
different mattress models to choose from
they have soft medium and firm
mattresses mattress is great for cooling
you
down if you sleep hot jesus christ a hot
sleeper
what the [ __ ] is that
although those people that i always make
fun of that wear the winter jacket and
have shorts on
you know they get in a bed any any sort
of [ __ ]
layer on them
they don't have any anti-freeze in them
um so if you're looking for a mattress
they're running hot you take the quiz
you order the mattress that you match to
and the mattress comes right to your
door ship for free
you don't ever need to go to a mattress
store again helix is awesome but don't
take my word for it helix was awarded
the number one best overall mattress
pick of 2020
by g in 2020 god knows we all laid
around that year and by gq and wired
magazine
helix has been around has been
recommended by multiple leading
chiropractors and doctors of sleep
medicine as a go-to solution for
improving sleep
just go to helixsleep.com
take their two-minute quiz and they'll
match you
to a customized mattress that will give
you the best sleep of your life patriots
driving
they have a 10-year warranty and you get
to try it out for a hundred nights risk
free
dump it off it's set up hey at that ten
the five the [ __ ] one-yard line
they have a 10-year warranty and you get
to try it out for 100 nights risk-free
they even pick it up for you if you
don't love it but you will
uh helix even has financing options you
can put it on layaway oh someday i'm
getting a good night get a good night's
sleep and flexible payment plans so a
great night's sleep is never far awake
uh helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at
helixsleep.com that's helix sleep.com
for up to 200 off all mattress orders
and two free pillows h-e-l-i-x
sleep
dot com
all right and with that in with that
that's great this is perfect
masshole malts
all right i got a patriots game on in
the background i can't even get through
my advertising without screaming and
yelling here this
this is perfect
masshole mark waltz
dear breakfast bill
and mr themeless big fan of you both
bill for the laughs andrew for the music
taste everybody always
[ __ ] gives andrew a shout out for his
great music taste long time listener
first time writing in i currently live
in la
as an actor
i roll what do you mean
it's a great thing to try it takes a lot
of balls to do that uh bill in your last
podcast you were talking about malts i
figured you get a real kick out of this
i grew up
uh a soda jerk
a soda jerk does that mean you work the
soda fountain at some point i'm from a
town called
yarmouth port on cape cod dude cape cod
massachusetts
[ __ ] clam diggers my grandfather
great great great great back in 1889 was
the postmaster general town selectman
and the pharmacist
all right let me do that in boston
actually he was the postmaster general
town selectman and the pharmacist
he built an ice cream soda fountain and
my extremely ornery father still runs it
today
five generations later it just turned
132 this summer dude i'm going to this
place what's the name of it
anyway if the chocolate malts are still
sitting heavy
i'm including a recipe for ice cream
sodas below
what a good [ __ ] which are a lighter but
just as good and you can add your malt
in case you're wondering why i didn't
include the name of this extremely
well-described landmark it's because i
know you like figuring [ __ ] out if you
ever find yourself on the cape with the
family
head to provincetown i've never been
there
that's way out on the cake
uh
right at the end and go you almost go
back to boston it curls all the way back
around again and go to
macmillan wharf
and learn about the pirate
sam bellamy
and the sh now is this actually a real
pilot or a pirate or is this like some
gay bar that has a theme
because you are in uh provincetown
and the shipwreck of wellfleet and the
recovered gold
the witch
his lover in the story is my distant
relative
dude this is like this started off like
something i was into now this sounds
like some conspiracy theory babble
did your other personality just kick um
her family name is the same as the ice
cream soda fountain okay he's giving me
mysteries here patriots on the goal line
they're playing smash mouth big ten
football no he [ __ ] dumps it off to
the tight end coming off the line
two touchdowns baby
matt jones the upstart
the upstart ladies and gentlemen my eyes
are too [ __ ] up is that 13 to 13 yes
it is we got a game
we got a game bat battle
um all right
if the thought of searching for
something sounds like a whole [ __ ]
thing right now which it often does [ __ ]
it the store is called uh block your
ears if you want to go on the [ __ ]
little
magical mystery tour there halletts
anyway it's all weird new england [ __ ]
but whatever go down some internet
rabbit hole for the sake of halloween
i'm gonna do it man that's that's a
great story
there's witches and pirates and [ __ ]
soda fountains i mean that's that's
that's not the love
wait do witches date pirates is that how
it goes
and uh what do they call that what do
those nerds call that middle-earth world
whatever the [ __ ] it is uh appreciated
seeing you and kirk fox and reservation
dogs thank you hope to work with you one
day go bruins go [ __ ] yourself all right
dude this is supposed to be lighter
a pine ice cream
hershey's chocolate syrup salsa slash
club soda
get yourself some good ice cream none of
that [ __ ] made with the water well which
one's made with water haagen-dazs is
preferable for store-bought go with
chocolate don't be an [ __ ] all right
i wish every recipe was written like
this get yourself a pint glass because
you won't have the right [ __ ] glass
for this anyway dude i have ice cream
soda glasses
somebody gave them to me for my birthday
all right
so you watch your [ __ ] mouth you
think i'm not serious uh get a big spoon
nothing crazy just bigger than the
average uh cereal spoon
first put about two ounces of chocolate
syrup in the pint glass then about two
to three ounces of the ice cream now
mash work the syrup and the ice cream
into a paste
if you're looking at the stone cone
creamery add a little more ice cream if
needed you can also add malt at this
point but don't go overboard
a little goes a long way with malt
listen guys speaking like a pro now
at a at a paste consistency start adding
a little club soda back in the day
soda fountains had a way to pull toward
yourself for streaming soda and push
back
for a very thin forced shot
oh so if you pulled you got more if you
push back you go oh yeah it's kind of
like the uh the pulse button on the
mixer keep mixing add a bit more club
soda
the head is going to start getting big
because of all of the cream
then you can see it settling through
keep adding club soda and keep stirring
until the pint glass is about three
quarters full should have a big head of
dude if i ever work with you i'm going
to watch you do this should have a big
head of chocolate foam now take a big
scoop of chocolate ice cream and place
it on the side of the glass
smashing it on the rim
to set the scoop in place of the rim
insert the straw in a long spoon and
enjoy you can make them with any flavor
as long as you have the syrup and the
corresponding ice cream
don't mix
cheers in other words don't use
strawberry syrup with chocolate i got it
what a good [ __ ]
he's the good [ __ ]
soda fountain man let me know
how to be a fat [ __ ] alright the milkman
way of life is still around
all right i have mentioned
in the past how when i was a kid
before inflation nothing nothing
third down baby
um
sorry just strung out the run really
nicely
um
yeah i was saying how you know milkman
had could have a stay-at-home wife if he
wanted to
right and all he did was just deliver
milk pick up the empties deliver the
milk it was just like
you know
like there's a real like something i
don't know
don't listen all this [ __ ] social
media [ __ ] where everybody's saying you
just got to keep pushing yourself to be
better to get better to do more to make
more to achieve and all of that [ __ ] and
that's that's a great way to have your
life go flying by
um
as i've learned after [ __ ] 30 years
of doing just that
um
you know you did a bunch of [ __ ] you saw
a bunch of stuff but how much of it were
you actually living
so um
i always look back at some of those jobs
like what if i just [ __ ] drove a milk
truck
just drove that around town
you know
breaking balls with the other guys down
at the [ __ ] place you know you drop
it off you come home come home for lunch
stay-at-home wife has a sandwich ready
for you like the whole old school
thing right and just saying how it went
away because of inflation and all of
that crap every august we print like a
trillion dollars and act like this ponzi
scheme is still working
um
well
this guy claims the milkman way of life
is still around dear billy burger with a
large fries burr
i've noticed the past few weeks
listening to the mmp and anything better
that you've brought up how you used to
be able to support a family and have a
stay-at-home white life while working as
a milkman yeah right like a simple
having a regular just blue-collar job
around town
even like a mailman i think even then
you know even if you're in the [ __ ]
union and all of that [ __ ]
you still need that second income it
seems
i mean granted back in the day the kids
weren't going i want an ipad
you know
which back then they're literally asking
for like a spaceship
um
i would just like to inform you that in
some parts of the world that is still
the case my father lives in nova scotia
canada and until about two years ago he
did just that
that's awesome he started in 1990 he
woke up at 3 a.m five days a week for
almost 30 years he delivered
door-to-door to local restaurants into
convenience stores luckily he was able
to sell his milk route to someone else
before the covert struck
uh it wasn't a glamorous life we lived
but my brother and i never went without
yeah playing sports always food on the
table lots of presents at christmas a
typical middle class white trash
upbringing yeah that's that's my
wheelhouse right there did tom brady
just run for a first down
at 53 years of age did he just do that
44 years of age
look at this takes off right up the
middle
nobody saw that coming
um why don't people like wrap their arms
around somebody when they go to tackle
he can't even believe it holy [ __ ] i
made it
um
the typical middle class white trash
upbringing that's my wheelhouse right
there you live in a duplex right your
neighbors smell your food and they hear
the arguments my mother stayed home with
us until we were in high school and old
enough to take care of ourselves uh he
didn't get paid a salary or an hourly
wage either he made his money from
buying milk from a local dairy and
reselling it i learned a lot about work
ethic when he would take me with him in
the summers dude that's like the bronx
tale riding around on the bus
um that's awesome just wanted to let you
know that the milkman lifestyle isn't a
thing of the past yet he now spends his
days managing the liquor store to keep
himself busy he's also a bald pasty [ __ ]
like you
big fan and thanks for all the laughs
and go [ __ ] yourself dude i think that i
gotta be honest with you i think that is
an amazing life
to do that
and uh to work like that
you know there's that great sense of
satisfaction and you're really providing
a service
you know then i'm sure there was times
people needed milk and they didn't have
the money he said don't worry get me
next week because you guys were all on
like a first name basis i mean that's
the [ __ ]
um
man tampa bay is just not playing well
look at brady like jesus christ
these guys are all more athletic than me
if they would just try as hard as i do
we wouldn't keep getting these stupid
penalties or was it a time up
i don't know what
um look at this superhero trying to sell
me a [ __ ] suv
piercing blue eyes he just winked at me
i think i want to buy this
um
thought that was captain america then he
had wings captain america doesn't have
wings does he have wings
i thought the hawk guy had wings and
then captain america drove around in a
jeep i thought he was an army guy
i don't i don't know they just had thor
now thor's
[ __ ] hanging out of one like
[ __ ] ace ventura
all right australia beatings
uh i love australia
i haven't been there in a long time this
guy says long time listener i saw you
here years ago and it was incredible
um
yeah i really miss going down there i
just don't know how to do it with my
kids
i really don't so um
i have to figure that out i'll have to
wait till they get a little bit bigger
or whatever
um
[Music]
i've had such a great time every time i
went down there
[ __ ] people down there are hilarious
really really funny people just a fun
and the most beautiful coasts and oceans
i've ever seen in my life and it's so
funny is
those were the most tempting oceans to
go into and they are littered with
sharks down there
um which by the way i saw this amazing
youtube video no i'm sorry instagram
thing uh this woman like taking fish
hooks out of sharks mouths and they were
coming up to her like dogs
you know
i hope we don't [ __ ] up the world beyond
repair before we figure out how awesome
a lot of animals that we think are
[ __ ] or fish or whatever that we
think are awful
and you know
it's really an abusive relationship that
we have with animals and we you know we
blame so many of them just because we're
afraid of them
this reality is there's no reason why we
should ever even come in contact with
the shark um australia beatings um oh
jesus yeah i saw some of this i was
wondering if you heard about what was
going on here it's very unsettling the
measures the authorities are taking the
physical brutality against people
sitting outside in the middle of nowhere
without a mask on is psychotic
yeah that sounds crazy i'm sure you've
seen the videos of people being beaten
with batons for their own safety
um that's not why they're beating him at
this point they're just sick of waiting
for them to get on board
uh beaten mate beaten um yes just
yesterday a member of the government
said the people who don't cooperate will
starve
um
yeah
yeah it's gonna i just i hate to say it
but this is the route it's gonna go
listen mate whatever anyone believes is
their own right
yes whatever you believe is your own
right until you're hurting other people
and even if the government wants to err
on the side of caution fine but what
kind of society are they creating when
this is the tone also the beatings all
right yeah the beatings are terrible
what also is bad is to not get
vaccinated and continue help spreading a
virus and you're round about killing
people's grandparents or their fat uncle
or whatever i mean let's
i mean what's going on
is
nuts
on both sides both sides are crazy and
yelling at each other and spiking
gallons of milk in convenience stores
and
beating somebody who's not wearing a
mask because they're outside but they're
not near anybody like beating them like
what are you doing like all of it is
[ __ ] nuts and um
but unfortunately not surprising because
um
war is still legal
you know and that is solving a problem
with violence
you know
and uh that's how human beings are it's
[ __ ] ridiculous that we've been
around this
long that this is what we do and you see
all the fallouts and all the
documentaries about all of this [ __ ] and
that we still end up doing stuff like
that i think it's absolutely horrific
that they're beating their own citizens
and i the same way i think it's
absolutely horrific
that
someone um
you know you want to get vaccinated fine
i don't give a [ __ ] about that but you
at least wear a goddamn mask but like
you're not even going to do that
and or act like you you know do the
passive aggressive like not
you know put it on properly and you
could you could kill somebody
and you're so [ __ ] wrapped up in your
own [ __ ]
i mean
it's just not as obvious as just walking
up and beating somebody i mean that's
just a horrible thing to see but like
i don't know i don't get it um
but i'm not gonna tell anybody what to
do you could do whatever the [ __ ] you
want to do but i mean this what's going
on down in australia
is this is gonna be
you know hopefully
you know modern medicine is going to
solve it the way they've solved
everything else and they don't get
credit for [ __ ] slowing down the aids
epidemic and now you can live with it i
mean what they've done is incredible i
had a ruptured appendix in 1980 and i'm
still here because of doctors and nurses
because of what they did 40 [ __ ]
years ago so i danced with what brung me
i'm sticking with this and the internet
is brand [ __ ] new and there's no
rules of libel or slander
and you just look at how
i don't know there's people now all of a
sudden think the world is flat i mean
and that is a
symptom of the internet and these giant
uninformed think tanks that are going on
it's just uh it is what it is i do i'm
really sorry that that's going on down
there
um
yeah but human beings uh in power solve
things with violence
they always do oh my god no [ __ ] way
look at that dawg what a big play we're
taking out oh we're gonna win we're
gonna win this [ __ ] game
pulling out all the stops
i think bill belichick maybe you know
some of these [ __ ]
sports talk radio guys when brady won
the super bowl and they were sitting
there going oh does that mean that
belichick didn't do anything i think he
took that personally
i mean that's like the second trick play
we've called this game
i love it
all right
okay here we go so anyways
um
i do not condone beating people that
don't believe in what you're doing
um all right men not organizing
hey billy bulbus bollocks
i was listening to one of your many
podcast clips on youtube and one thing
you said really stuck with me you
mentioned how women are better than men
when it comes to getting things done in
their benefit because they're able to
organize themselves into groups in order
to champion for a cause uh
yeah they are good at that they're good
at threatening men
you know
on a one-on-one level in a relationship
all the way up although you know they're
losing big time
you know
in texas if you're if you're if you're
pro-choice if you're pro-life i don't
know you think they're winning i don't
i'm not gonna get involved in that [ __ ]
ain't stepping in that [ __ ] swamp um
anyway he said i think it was your
explanation of why feminists on top of
having so much influence don't seem to
have a male counterpart
i don't even know what that means
and he goes i have to disagree with
there disagree there i don't i don't
know what you're talking about wait
comes the thing organized because
they're better able to
to organize themselves into groups in
order to champion for a cause i think it
was your explanation as to why feminists
on top of having so much influence don't
seem to have a male counterpart
what does that mean they don't have a
male counterpart
first of all dude you're listening to a
podcast this is me just trying to fill
up an hour so god knows i don't remember
half the [ __ ] i say i have to disagree
with there oh you know what i agree with
you you're right i shouldn't have said
that [ __ ] this is the new me
it just ends these type of conversations
yeah you're right man why why did i say
that uh from my experience the biggest
problem is that men who do get together
to stand up for their rights are either
ignored or immediately labeled as
hateful
misogynists
um i highly recommend you check out a
documentary about the men's right
movement titled the red pill
interestingly enough it was created by a
lady
documentarian by the name of casey j
who prior to the production of the
documentary was a feminist in fact the
documentary was originally made in an
attempt to show how evil men's right
activists were
um
okay
i don't know much about men's rights
activists i remember a few of them tried
to like
attach themselves to my podcast and i
was reading what they were writing it
just sounded like a bunch of guys that
weren't getting laid
i'm all for divorce guys though
going to divorce court what happens in
divorce court
to most of the time men but
straight across the board to who was
ever making more money
because now you're seeing that with
women now that they're getting
opportunities and they're [ __ ]
crushing it and they're making a lot of
money and all of a sudden they get
divorced and you know the guy starts
asking for ridiculous alimony i mean
it's just
it's a [ __ ] travesty whoever it
happens to
i just don't understand why there's two
people involved
like both of you your your relationships
failed
so there should be 50 50 responsibility
and how one person
who like
makes less money gets to basically live
the same lifestyle and just have the
person they don't no longer love removed
from the situation i mean that's
that's ridiculous
to do that to a man or a woman um anyway
what's sad is that her abandonment of
the physical back to the uh the
documentarian who wanted to do a thing
to show men's rights people
looking like [ __ ]
and then she became one i guess
i guess feminists say she has stockholm
syndrome what's said is that her
abandonment of the feminist label arose
when she found herself attacked
and slandered
by those who once considered
she once considered friends in the
feminist community simply because she
was giving a voice to a different
perspective
yeah there's a lot of that on in
everywhere
from sports fans to activists
um
and especially on the internet people
like to hear people say what they think
makes them feel better it makes them
feel right
makes them feel smart i don't know what
it is
um
anyway also i won't lie maybe i'm just a
crier but some of the interviews shown
in the video made me shed some big ones
in any case thanks for reading my
message love your humor your podcasts
and your acting thank you best wishes to
your family peace love and go [ __ ]
yourself i gotta be honest with you um i
have enough issues with women i don't
need to watch
um i don't i don't because
i i over correct the other way so i need
to [ __ ] be a little more empathetic
haven't said that i'm not gonna i don't
let myself get walked all over i'll take
the fight
i'll sleep on the couch i don't give a
[ __ ] boyfriend interrupts sex time to
close curtains
hey billy blue balls
hey billy blue balls um
what do we got here long time lady
listener here
i've been with my lovely boyfriend for
two years and despite being very much in
love
i'm starting to get irritated by our sex
lives
every time he initiates and i put that
in quotes because how he initiates is
sending me a message while he's in the
other room while jerking off
oh brother expecting me to go to him and
skip over all the foreplay
oh yeah he's trying to postmate [ __ ]
this guy is trying to skip all the
common attractions get right to the car
chase
and since i'm kind of easy and i like to
have a good time i think i trained him
not to try
all right well look at you taking a
responsibility for a little bit of it
that's great
it shows that you're a fully formed
adult on some level so what i would do
is i yeah i think you need to sit down
and have a talk with them that's what
i'm
another thing he does is if we do start
off and get in the mood
is get up in the middle of undressing
close all the windows and curtains
not an inch of exposure was tolerated
and returned like you would after
pausing a game the problem is he forgets
it's an online game and by the time he's
done closing all the windows and
curtains i'm no longer in the mood
well how many [ __ ] windows do you
have also with all these [ __ ]
perverts and cameras they got drones
he's probably doing you a favor
i've addressed this before but to no
available he's paranoid someone is
watching slash recording us while we're
[ __ ]
that's a good thing to do though
be a little paranoid i'm sure there are
creeps out there but i feel he's blowing
it out of proportion
no pun intended it's becoming a boring
routine where i'm sitting there half
naked watching him slowly close the
curtains all over the place
that's like when you go to a diner and
they bring you your eggs and they like
the toast is coming it's like eggs over
easy i need toast with this for the yolk
then you just sit in there while the
eggs are getting cold her eggs are
getting cold buddy
um anyway how do i convince him that
nobody gives a [ __ ] about our sex life
uh i used to walk around naked in my
apartment not giving a [ __ ] but he's
very wary of even a few seconds of
exposures exposure thanks and [ __ ] you
p.s are you doing a europe tour anytime
soon all right um
okay so you're more of an exhibitionist
you walk around naked in your apartment
without the [ __ ] uh you know
curtains closed i guarantee you some guy
figured out a way to look at you and
jerk off because that's how guys are it
just is it is what it is
okay
it's like snow in the winter
you're [ __ ] a woman and you're
walking around in your apartment naked
eventually you one day you're going to
look and there's going to be a guy's
head looking in the window it's just
it's going to happen
all right
we do not live in a perfect world act
accordingly
um
so i don't know what i i would yeah you
just this is easy you just need to talk
to him
just say listen how about you go
downtown a little bit instead of [ __ ]
you know
going right to uh cruising altitude
[Laughter]
this guy goes right to the end of the
fireworks
the 1812 overture
um that's an easy conversation the um
the blinds
i don't know well let me ask you this
are you are you someone that gets off
from the fact that maybe somebody is
kind of watching
you know you're walking around naked and
you know
back in my day
old single bill i met a number of women
they they they liked being a little bit
of a exhibitionist i have no idea if
he's going the other way
you know
maybe that's turning you off beyond it
getting you out of the mood is it also
turning you off a little bit
you know this is what he should if
that's what i would do if i if i was
paranoid like him and you liked walking
around naked in the apartment what i
would do is i'd bang you at night
okay
i'd stick your head out the window and
i'd pull the curtain down right to right
above you know where the [ __ ] stamp is
and i'd be banging you from behind you
could have your head out the window and
we're both happy see a relationship is
all about compromise everybody
um
that's it
you get a little fresh air you feel like
you went for a walk
[Laughter]
um
so anyway that is the uh sorry about
that everybody that is the podcast um
i'm watching this here tom terrific is
going down the field there's three
minutes left in the game is he gonna
cover my bet first down tom brady
this is why gambling sucks is cause i
need him to score a [ __ ] touchdown
no wait no no wait i'm gonna lose this
bet
i forgot what my spread was it was minus
six
and they're [ __ ] down by what one
so they score a touchdown that's seven
oh you [ __ ] i'm gonna push
how about a round of applause for
[ __ ] vegas
i mean does anybody do it better than
vegas
how do they do it
how did the sam rothstein they just pick
the perfect number of course i wasn't
going to go 4-0 on my bets what the [ __ ]
was i thinking
all right
look at bruce i mean this is just his
dream gig he's 69 years old he's on his
way out
he's got a player coach the greatest
quarterback of all time
got himself a super bowl ring last year
i'm surprised he came back
cool dude like that you know with his
kango hats and [ __ ] i would figure he'd
just be
get himself a cigar and go off into the
sunset but the man loves the game
it's one of the hardest stairs i've ever
seen in my life he's still thinking
about running out of bounce
um
all right
this is the end of the podcast but i'm
going to stay on here for the final
couple minutes here of this patriots
game
tom brady all right
all you guys are faster than me but no
one knows the game better than me just
do what the [ __ ] i say and we're gonna
win another one okay
on two on two
ready break
bill belichick
squinting is always emotionless second
and eight it says right on the grass
case i couldn't read it at the bottom of
my [ __ ] screen
tom brady going for it all
[ __ ]
i thought that was gonna drop in there
all right third and eight
third and eight
this is this is going gonna be the exact
thing i didn't want these [ __ ]
[ __ ] are gonna kick a field goal to
win it i bet against my own goddamn team
jesus christ
another miscommunication there
he's like i threw it to the back
shoulder there
how many times we got to do it in
practice
oh the water boy's coming out bobby
boucher
bill belichick where the [ __ ] my son
someone was mentioning this
the other oh dean delray was talking
about how football pants are slowly just
becoming shorts
like not only there are no knee pads
most of them don't even wear knee pads
the pants are above the knee
which is amazing to me
because knee injuries end your [ __ ]
career a lot of these guys
the flashy guys there the the the what
they call it the uh
running backs the wide receivers
the guys that get all the [ __ ] ladies
right they need to be fast
i would have every [ __ ] i'd be wearing
that barry buns [ __ ]
middle age thing middle ages thing that
he [ __ ] wore
here we go again same [ __ ] play
he juggled it out of bounds
now it's fourth and eighth now they kick
a field goal
now they kick a field goal they go up
it will make it 19 to 17 and i've lost
my bet because even if the patriots come
down and kick a field goal
at least we can win the [ __ ] game
there's enough time we can win the game
ah jesus he should have had it
i mean look at this guy 44 years old he
just he puts it right
what does he gotta do does he gotta
[ __ ] hand it to you
i got a feeling this guy's gonna miss it
he's gonna push it wide right he already
[ __ ] one up today
come on you [ __ ] bird push it right push
it right yeah you [ __ ] bastard
good for you good for you you don't have
to put your house on the market
all right i'm not gonna sit here for two
minutes of timeouts and [ __ ]
commercials
um
son of a [ __ ]
we better win this [ __ ] game if i'm
gonna lose my bet all right that's it
that's the podcast go [ __ ] yourselves
um have a great couple days and i'll
check in on you on thursday
you